قال جيش الاوكراني في تقريره الصباحينه
خاض 26 اشتباكا قتاليا مع القوات الروسيه
على الجبهات كافه خلال ساعات الاربعه
والعشرين الاخيره واضاف ان القوات الروسيه
شنت سبعا وسبعين غاره جويه واربعه واربعين
هجوما بمخذوفات صاروخيه متعدده وفي اقليم
دومباس قال الجيش الاوكراني انه يواصل
هجومه باتجاه مدينه
هجوميه روسيه على محوري افديفكا ومرينكا
نشرت وكاله رايانوفسكي مقطع فيديو نقلته
عن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت انه يوفق
لحظه استهداف مستودع ذخيره تابعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في بلده كيس ليفكا بمقاطعه
خيرسون جنوبيه البلاد تظهر الصور الملتقطه
عبر طائره استطلاع لحظه تصاعد الدخان من
الموقع المستهدف دون ذكر اي تفاصيل بشان
الخسائر